très bien nous allons retarder enchaîné
avec cette troisième et dernière table
ronde consacrée donc à l'exécution des
peines et à la fin du désarmement pénale
je voudrais vous dire tout d'abord que
je me sens parfaitement à l'aise dans
cette convention sécurité même si nous
abordons un volet aujourd'hui à
l'instant plus judiciaire car il est
évident que la chaîne pénale c'est la
prévention le maintien de l'ordre
et quand cela a échoué c'est au tour de
la justice d'intervenir et donc de
sanctionner de faire exécuter les peines
est donc tout à fait naturel que nous
ayons cette troisième table ronde
relatives à l'exécution des peines mais
je rassure comme l'indiqué tout à
l'heure eric woerth en introduisant
notre convention il y aura plus tard une
convention consacrée entièrement à
l'institution judiciaire dans tout c'est
évidemment dimension alors je voudrais
dire d'un mot qu'au fond avant de
présenter à nos différents intervenants
brice hortefeux l'a très bien dit tout à
l'heure ce qui nous différenciait de la
gauche et la droite entre la culture de
l'excusé et la culture en ce qui nous
concerne la responsabilité
je crois pouvoir dire que la gauche qui
aujourd'hui s'inscrit finalement dans un
courant idéologique qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
ne croyez surtout pas qu'elle est abonné
à la bibliothèque rose je crois que nous
avons affaire à une politique
parfaitement voulue par madame taubira
non seulement madame taubira mais
également le premier ministre et le
président la république puisque c'est la
ligne taubira qui l'a emporté sur la
ligne valls vous souvenez après les
affrontements de juillet 2013 entre les
deux ministres du même gouvernement
et que en réalité à gauche on considère
que la criminalité est un sous-produit
de la misère et que donc l'auteur de
l'infraction qui et victimes
d'inégalités sociales et lui-même est
avant tout une victime de la société
c'est en cela qu'il faut comprendre la
culture de l'excusé nous n'avons pas du
tout cette appréhension du phénomène de
la criminalité
nous considérons qu'il y a une part
évidente de libre arbitre dans chaque
individu qui choisit soit de rester dans
le droit chemin choix d'enfreindre la
loi
à partir de là quand la gauche est
arrivée au pouvoir nous allons aborder
ces questions là elle s'est trouvée
confrontée à la surpopulation carcérale
refus de construire des prisons et donc
à partir de là il faut évidemment vider
les prisons soient en eux les
remplissant pas soit en faisant qu'elle
se vide le plus vite possible
voilà en gros ce que je souhaitais dire
sur la différence essentielle d'
approche de cette question entre la
majorité et l'opposition qui a vocation
à redevenir majorité demain alors j'ai
le plaisir de vous présenter
autour de moi donc en fonction de du de
l'ordre d'intervention donc le premier
volet de cette table ronde sera
consacrée à la lutte contre le
terrorisme et sera développé par eric
ciotti qui a été eric eric ciotti qui
qui a présidé la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur la surveillance des
filières jihadistes guillaume larrivé à
ma gauche qui nous éclairera plus
particulièrement sur la le phénomène de
la radicalisation en milieu
pénitentiaire il est d'ailleurs l'auteur
de deux rapports sur ces sujets le
deuxième volet sera consacré à l'or au
désarmement pénale et les moyens d'en
sortir bien entendu je donnerai la
parole alexandre julia rice de
l'institut pour la justice que tout le
monde connaît c'est le point de vue des
citoyens
le point de vue des victimes si vous
voulez la peut dire vous pouvez le faire
et courageux ensuite aux professeurs
juste et avocat maître louis vogel eric
ciotti de nouveaux interviendra sur
cette question là pour nous parler aussi
du parc pénitentiaire
hervé mariton sur la réalité des peines
sur laquelle il souhaitait intervenir
le troisième volet sera consacré à la
lutte contre les récidives et
l'extension des peines planchers or i o
réitérant interviendra mon binôme
secrétaires nationales à justice claude
goasguen ensuite brice hortefeux qui
doit nous rejoindre tout à l'heure nous
dira quelle est la priorité qui doit
être celle menée contre la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine et enfin annie
genevard qui nous donnera son point de
vue sur la manière de lutter plus
efficacement contre les occupations
illicites que nous connaissons tous et
enfin moi même je conclurai rapidement
sur la question de la délinquance des
mineurs et des propositions que nous
vous ferons
voilà donc vous voyez que le programme
est très nourris très chargé
donc je demande à chacun et chacune
d'entre vous évidemment d'être
extrêmement synthétique je cède la
parole en premier à eric ciotti